boyfriends yes or no in high school
boyfriends yes yes serious boyfriend no
no one you ever said I'm in love no you
had not been in love yet
no bill was the first guy you loved no
no there no no there was somebody before
him somebody before bill that you would
have considered marrying know I went out
of considered but in love but in love
and we never hear about this guy always
this guy probably pissed he didn't of
different people and I liked a lot of
them you were popular I was pretty
popular right yeah I was okay pop right
right yeah yeah
boys were not your problem boys were not
my problem but I never I had not until I
met bill met anybody that I thought I
would ever marry you were not the
cheerleader type though now you were the
studious act I was the student and
student government you know that kind of
stuff yeah no kidding yeah so you must
have somewhere in the back of your mind
figured hey you know I like I'll tell
you another story so I read the type
that would promise people free lunches
and and a more study hall or you know
great homecoming parties I mean that
kind of thing and so that I remember I
did run for president of my high school
government as I remember did you win no
of course not did some guy who you know
and and and it was sort of for a day
because a lot of my you know boyfriends
they said you know come on we're not
gonna elect a girl I mean what are you
doing this for I said well because you
guys I have some ideas what I want to do
okay fine you know somebody else wins
comes to semen he goes you know I would
really like it if you'd help me oh yeah
so I said sure
oh you were really nice I was nice I
wanted like you know doing things what
can I say